the cdc says more than 100 million
americans are now fully vaccinated
against cova 19.
and on tuesday the u.s is restricting
travel from india where daily infections
are numbering hundreds of
thousands michael george has the latest
california health officials are working
to dispel covid19 myths
and convince young people to get
vaccinated young people have this
misconception
that clovitt is no big deal it is a big
deal
in social media there are a lot of
rumors going around about how the
vaccine is not important or how we don't
need it because we're not at high risk
the u.s
has reached president biden's goal of
200 million vaccines administered
in his first 100 days in office but
vaccine hesitancy and slowing
vaccination rates
are a new battlefront in the war on
kovid 19.
arkansas is one of more than 10 states
not ordering all available doses
36 percent of arkansas residents have
received at least one dose
but that's well below the national total
this as the nation's pacific northwest
is dealing with a new spike in cases
our hospitalizations have nearly doubled
what they were a week ago
and starting tuesday the u.s is
restricting travel from india
where a devastating surge has pushed
daily new infections above
400 thousand the federal government is
sending supplies
such as desperately needed oxygen to
india india helped us last year in some
of the darkest days of the u.s pandemic
sending assistance in our hour of need
india is working to get shots into
people's arms but with more than 1.3
billion people
there's a long road ahead michael george
cbs
news